[Music]
in childsplay news tasks play scary ones
right a moment from our sponsors go to
sip it's in Rowland Heights in Westwood
for some delicious drinks I finished
mine it was watermelon fresca Oh mine
was rainbow and I looked wave where are
you what's boba very much blueberry I
like because it's not too sweet
it's a good amount of sweet and the
Boba's are the right consistency thank
you now on to our regularly scheduled
program hey submitted by pineapple on
pizza hell yeah gusting Gordon Ramsay
himself said that pineapple does not
belong on pizzas too juicy it's [ __ ]
weird
she also don't know how to make pad thai
so there you go you make some great beef
wellington maybe he's just against Asian
dishes mm-hmm
a Mexican police force has been armed
with slingshots after their guns were
confiscated
you can confiscate from the police off
yeah Mexico of all places like what is
she doing yeah the other end just rocks
yeah right well Ron even darters like
they're gonna get this dude [ __ ] like
go back with your hands up right it's
not doesn't even hurt it's just mildly
annoying when they hit yeah he was like
like holes everyone in a room he's like
give me your [ __ ] guns like how do
you do that please look at my I don't
know I don't know the Mexican doesn't
know how to do Mexican damn yeah give me
a gun so now that cartels really gonna
take over right there's gonna blast all
of them and they're gonna [ __ ] be
reloading like this they've taken over
oh yeah
yeah there's there's some villages there
so [ __ ] dope what they did is the
citizens actually kicked out the
cattlemen and the government right about
this cuz they're like wow nobody's
taking care of us we gotta take care of
ourselves and then they have checkpoints
there to make sure that anyone that
comes through are not armed they can't
do any political propaganda nothing
because they're like all the cops that
the government were sending they're not
people of our community so they're part
of the cartels yeah so they were being
corrupt even the politicians they're
like nah we want to have our own
elections and I thought that was really
people out how do they how do they
protect our borders
oh they're are on their own militia yeah
I saw a little like many document on
this guy who did the same thing and he
was like seventy years old and he was
like a really revered man in
neighborhood and he made like their
little village independent but then
we'll kind of ruin his credibility the
other 15 or girlfriend
[Music]
and then they I saw that one too but
what ended up happening is they ended up
being the cartel - but this other one
I'm talking about that guy ended up
being a cartel no they ended up being
corrupt and taking when they took get
too much power
cuz he's like tell me this is cuz I'm
already dead yeah but this other village
I'm talking about is they have fair
elections and they rotate I love the way
they vote yeah yeah they actually stand
in line in front of the person that
they're voting for so you visually
conceived yeah who's winning
that's and they rotate and if you're not
you can't actually want to do it you
have to be nominated yeah so if I'm like
you know what I think TIFF will be a
great president TIFF just has to accept
it even if I don't want ya and in the
guy that was doing it he's actually like
a college professor and he says well
when I become mayor or whatever I'm
gonna take like a third of my paycheck
it's gonna be gone yeah I'm doing it for
the community feel like that's how
America used to be in the beginning
because he used to like have to get
nominated and then also used to have to
live in the city or the community that
you represented you didn't just live in
Washington DC that's true oh we do that
anymore
because it got corrupt anyway so this
story here so this is a town in the
state of veracruz the town's name is
Alvarado how can we say Veracruz would
be an exit but not Alvarado
very good observation Jeana I was
wondering the seems like Veracruz and
Alvarado right they should ask your
brain my brain I can't speak to my brain
yeah you can look up look up and he
talked to it
I saw no one's home right now yeah no
I'm never home I saw a video of a white
girl she's like today we're gonna Thais
but she said today we're gonna eat eel
oats and I want to kill why no it was
awful
today we're gonna go get ellos no way
yeah I don't know for me sometimes
Politis words that are Spanish like I
just I can't say it in an English way
yes I can't be like but then you can say
Los Angeles because you're not like lost
I like my brain picks and chooses oh do
you say Bonilla a pentagon unicornia
because it's from South America
say it again brother meconium what is it
is that you say about Patagonia is para
Honea I don't like the South American
like mountain mountain I really hope
that you know on your deathbed that's
the last word that you say come to me
find me in peponi oh geez our ages right
uh I think it's the age Woodson when
it's in the beginning of the word oh
yeah yeah I think so I don't know I
don't know Spanish that depending on
what like where you speak Spanish
because like my Venezuelan friend
pronounced things differently than a
Mexican double ELLs are Jane's to some
yes we're [ __ ] yeah yeah so back to this
thing here so what the governor finding
is that out of the 130 police officers
that were tested for firearms like
they're training only thirty of them
passed everyone's guns laying kind of I
don't know how do you explain to her
like whatever or not depends how you use
it you could be like like Charlie I
don't know what the super thing is just
like like
like I don't know I don't know yeah and
I hear it mainly for people from Mexico
City a Chilango is easy I just imagined
he was still training there like how do
you [ __ ] this challenge I don't even
know how to use it anyway so here's some
photos oh my god they're like neon
they're keep falling oh my mo to make it
look cool or something like so the mayor
started handing out these slingshots
kind of like that's wrong heresy it's
really very protest for them getting
their guns taken controller the gun
replacing it oh that's great that is
embarrassing this was in protest I see I
thought those guys were so incompetent
that the government gave up yeah well
that's the thing like the mayor is
saying like it's just they're not anyway
this isn't the first time that this
happened back in 2007 well he'd give
them [ __ ] week sling shots that were
issued two officers in Tijuana because
they were apparently they were in
collusion with drug traffickers but what
are they supposed to do because I feel
like the cartel is so strong there and
those guys are afraid for their lives
yeah
so they just want to do their job right
and but then if the cartel tells you to
do something you've got to do it or else
they're gonna kill your whole family
they should just pay the [ __ ] police
force more take care of their cops and
they wouldn't be so tempted to get
bribes from the [ __ ] cartel doesn't
have enough money in there to even do
that maybe if the cops felt like they
had the government had their back yeah
and everything was just in order yeah
then they wouldn't have to be so corrupt
mm-hmm yeah it's just all kinds of
[ __ ] up it's a mess but it's I fee I
feel like the government does that for
like a publicity so they're like yeah
we're cracking down on corruption guys
and it's gonna go back to business
I know
there was also reports of these cops I
got caught killing these journalists too
so like even journalists over there
getting murdered because they're
reporting the truth especially about the
corrupt government so then like now
journalists are scared to say anything
because they don't want to get killed
and that's been happening forever
dude there was this aw you guys know
that show cartel yeah yeah so the
producer for that show was location
scouting oh yeah we did an article on
this yeah or was it that was that too
but he got killed and he got killed then
he's just a [ __ ] producer
location yeah I wanted to go to Mexico
and the whole production crew good right
man I don't know what the hell I would
do if I was a cop and they took my gun
away and I only had a slingshot I'd be
like dude I think you would make good
use of it yeah you steal like sharp
steel and like [ __ ] shoot it you
imagine it like they hold like
criminally like they put the gun on your
back like wait I think what I would do
is have 50 cops with me everywhere I go
but but you just have a bunch of
cannibal just you know overwhelming with
numbers no that's crazy when we went to
Turkey had no no no Morocco Morocco they
had to there were always three cops
walking together and it was I forgot
holding hands touching shoulders
everywhere they were walking us three of
them so you can't penetrate them
it was weird cuz it's it's like when uh
squirrels tried to scare off a snake or
whatever like that squirrels but moles
or whatever they they stick together and
they get big like this so the traded
snake into thinking it like a big animal
why do you know that I was watching
Discovery Channel one time Diaby dope if
all three was locking arms like this
yeah
the thing to the cops think that would
they're tricking all the people to
soldiers in one like city cop so that's
how they had it was like two soldiers
and two soldiers escort the city cop
there's a city do they have guns and
stuff
damn like a boss and it's hot there too
so they must have sweaty shoulders all
babies thinkin that I just think about
one t-shirt or one t-shirt I'll be so
much easier right now you get armed a
guy in the middle has nothing do they
synchronize their walking like this yeah
oh so it's all like marching so someone
commits a crime it throws off their
whole sequence for like over I think
they practice relay races by tying their
feet together three-legged races yeah
the three-legged race that's in the
middle because he has no leg of his own
he's tied to these two guys he just gets
some left to speed up and get the eight
Kate around everywhere it's little I
just imagine the parents when they grab
their kids and swing though we got
pictures like that right I've yet to see
the photos QG over tagging me in your
captain cry now it was true
[Music]
[Music]